- Does anyone else with a sibling
with a disability have
this conversation a lot?
- Sheena, how can I find
someone to go on a date with?
- Wait, I should start from the beginning.
This is me and my little brother Sean.
Ever since he came
along, he was my best bud
and I just wanted to take care of him.
Before he turned one, we found out
that he had cerebral palsy, but to me
he was always just Sean.
So we were like any
other pair of siblings.
And for a while there
really got at each other.
(click)
But I swear, now we get along much better.
So my brother has cerebral palsy and a lot
of things in life are a little
more challenging for him.
One of those things is dating
but I decided I'm going
to sit down and talk
to him about dating and then
I'm going to find him a date.
(electronic beats)
So first I asked him, why is
it important for him to date?
- I feel lonely.
I want to be with someone.
I try my best and asking my friends
like if they want to go on coffee dates.
- Mhm.
It's hard to know who to ask out.
And when you just have things
in common and when you're just friends
and when it's a genuine
connection that could turn
into something more romantic.
But I feel like it's easier
for people who have no disability at all.
Like you, for example.
Me, I try and asking my
crush in middle school.
It was the junior-senior dance.
She stood me up.
I think that's hard for me to find someone
because my disability.
People just look at me weird.
My walking, my talking.
I feel like they say,
"I don't like, I don't
want to go out with that."
I just wish people more flexible.
- So what kind of stuff
would you want to do
if you got a girlfriend?
(electronic beats)
- I would want to do hand gliding.
(laughing)
- I'm talking about just
like everyday stuff.
- Okay.
Stuff like going on the
treadmill, working out.
- You guys are both going
to be on one treadmill
at the same time?
- Yeah
Singing, playing video games.
Playing board games, watching movies.
Going out.
- Other than the treadmill part,
all those sound like
really fun date ideas.
- Yeah.
- How about we find you a date?
- Yay.
- Since we are in the time of COVID,
we are going to be looking
for a virtual date, right?
And I will be using the power
of the internet to find this lady.
So I'm going to take a few
notes on what we are looking for
and what you want to share about yourself.
So how would you describe yourself?
- Funny, creative and outgoing.
- Yes. Very true.
What is something else
that you want people
to know about you?
- My shirt business.
- Of course.
Should we show people?
- Yeah.
- Let's see your shirt.
- Ta-da!
- All right.
So this is ink man.
- Yeah.
- And you have a few different
designs that you've drawn?
(popping)
And where did these come from?
These characters?
- I just thought of them.
My imagination.
- And where can we find
your art and your t-shirts?
- On my Instagram page.
- I think I have enough
information now to scour the web
and see if I can find a lovely lady
for you to go on a virtual date with.
- Awesome.
(sentimental piano music)
Sean has been wanting
a girlfriend for ages.
Like he has been talking
about wanting to go
on dates and meet someone for so long.
He just wants to experience romance
and love and not unrequited love.
We all just want to be
loved and to love, right?
And I sure hope he finds that one day.
And in the meantime, I'm going
to do what I can to help.
Okay, Sean.
I have found a few lovely
ladies who are interested
in going on a virtual date with
you and we're going to look
through them and you're
going to choose one.
- Okay.
Option number one, she's looking
for a long-term relationship
with someone who she can
be comfortable around
who is her best friend, and
they can have fun together.
And number two, she plays the
keyboard, plays video games.
Likes to go on hikes.
This is our final option.
She is looking for a man who is kind
and is able to get her
out of her shell a bit.
She loves movies and going to concerts.
Want to see more about her?
- Yeah.
- Hi, I'm Melissa.
I live outside of Pittsburgh, PA
and my hobbies are I like
reading and watching TV
and jigsaw puzzles.
- Yeah.
- Is she your winner?
- Yeah?
- Yes.
- All right.
We will be setting you up
on a date with Melissa.
- Yay.
- [Sheena] Hey bud, you
excited for your date today?
- Yeah.
- [Sheena] Then let's get ready.
- Hi.
- Hi, nice to meet you.
How are you?
- Oh I'm good, how are you?
- Good.
- Okay, I'm sitting in the other room
and I'm so nervous for him.
She seems very high functioning
and maybe even neuro-typical
with just some physical disabilities.
And that's something that's
really interesting about CP is
that CP is a very kind of umbrella term,
where there are a lot of variations
in what CP can look like.
So some people just have a little bit
of a waddle in their walk
and some muscle weakness
but they're totally neuro-typical.
Some people are very severely disabled
and need 24/7 care and can't
really do much on their own.
So Sean falls kind of in
the middle of everything.
And that's why he can
be so tricky, I think,
when it comes to dating
and finding a partner
because a lot of the people
he knows kind of fall
on either one end or the other.
He just needs to find someone
that will love him for who he is.
And it's not about the disability, right?
It's just about finding
someone who intellectually
can match him in a fun way.
We'll see how this goes.
How did it go?
- It went really well,
but I want to keep as friends
because she lives too far away.
And I don't want to move there.
- [Sheena] Yeah. That makes sense.
Well, I'm glad you had fun though.
And it sounds like you made a new friend.
- Yay.
I'm so excited to see
who else is out there.
And I want to keep on dating.
- So ladies, if he's your type
I am still down to match-make.
So hit us up.
Also, if anyone else knows
other ways to meet people
for people like Sean,
let us know.
(happy guitar music)